david pollock from the mothership former
nfl player joining
uh what did you think what do you think
of that david
about the t.o stuff yes
different um t.o
t.o would be a good word to describe
that um
because it just it seems like to me you
know outside guy looking in that
he was probably a little bit upset and
he voiced his frustration the last
couple years about not getting in and
you know this is kind of his way to i
guess to give it back to him a little
bit but i i don't i think you're right i
don't think we'll see a lot of it in the
future i think people
consider that an honor and should
consider that an honor and it's really
cool to see everybody on stage at the
same place
giving their speech and tio had the
right to do what he wanted to do but i
think it was more about kind of getting
back at everybody that didn't vote him
earlier yeah but what happens if you
sign this letter and then you don't go
to the ceremony
are they not going to allow you in the
hall of fame like
i don't know that's right that's the
thing there's no consequence though i
mean
there isn't he i think he knew he was
going to get in but
i think you could very easily say fine
if you want to do that then don't
you're not allowed at the ceremonies and
you're not getting in this year you know
next year
next year dan next year if you want to
try again you want to accept this
awesome honor and come to our place then
we'll have you in next year we'll have
you voted in and you can come and you
can give your speech
i'd be shocked if any other athlete took
this approach
to the hall of fame in the near future
this was just terrell owens doing
something that we're not surprised that
terrell owens did
all right let me let me get back to what
uh i wanted to talk to you about
uh and that's urban meyer with what
happened on friday
uh where we are right now and we got 14
days
for this committee to decide his future
uh you were strong with your opinion
uh out of the gate with urban meyer how
do you feel about his future there
my opinion doesn't change dan i still
have my opinion but what i think they're
going to do
is i think urban meyer the statement the
other day
the the zach smith interview i think the
groundwork has been laid
here's what urban meyer did he humanized
himself he took
he fell on the sword for lying i lied
but guess what
there's also no consequences for that
dan you know that they can lie to the
media
there is no consequence okay i'm sorry i
shouldn't have answered that to me
there's there's something more there
obviously but i think the groundwork's
being laid he released his statement
i think you'll get a couple games
suspension and i think urban mile will
be the coast next year at ohio state
from what we're seeing right now and
what we're hearing so you think he gets
suspended not fired
yes sir i think yeah i think bill i
think they'll suspend
yeah i just don't know why he kept this
coach on his staff though i know that
look he he has a loyalty to earl bruce
the former ohio state coach and it's his
grandson but
at some point you got to do what's best
for your program
not for some legacy with earl bruce's
grandson
in the end you're the ceo in the end
everything that happens on your watch
falls on you regardless and this is this
wasn't the guy's first offense
um irvin when he got asked about this
guy man have you ever lied for no reason
i mean have you ever just said no i i
didn't know this or
usually you have something to hide when
you say that right and
um so i think if you if you if you went
to utah
then and you went to gainesville and you
go to columbus
if you look in urban meyers meeting
rooms one of the things you'll always
find is the number one rule is respect
women
it's all over the place it's always
plastered all over the
the building where he gets at and i
i think i think there is an aspect of
that now that you can say did he
did he follow through with that was that
something that he did because
you obviously knew a little bit more
than than was let out obviously in the
first because he already apologized for
it and that's one thing that
i think you talk about taking a little
bit of a gain from somebody from
a credibility standpoint you probably
lose a little bit of that when it comes
to that aspect
wait you're saying when he was at utah
and at florida and ohio state that
there's
signs about respecting women absolutely
it's a big it's always a big thing that
you must respect women that that's not
going to be tolerated if you don't
respect one
it's a huge deal it has been for as long
as urban meyer has been in the spotlight
as long as he's been a coach it's been a
huge deal
and i didn't buy that he was
ill-prepared when he went to the media
day
and had his speech dan
i heard that too and and how long have
you been on air dan
well i've been doing this a long time
okay you've been on air for a long time
urban meyer has been in the spotlight
for a long time urban meyer has been
asked every question
under the sun you can't tell me that
urban meyer is caught off guard by any
question
you might you might go oh that's an
interesting question we've been
taught how to handle these questions
he's handled difficult questions in the
past so i don't
i don't buy into the like we give him
slack because he was cut off guard for a
question we get asked questions all the
time
and we know how to answer questions
unless there's something we have to hide
and you kind of you kind of skirt around
talking to david pollock the espn
college football analyst college game
day
is coming to south bend and that'll be
september 1st it's michigan versus notre
dame
i think lost in all of this with urban
meyer is the top 25 rankings came out
and normally we chop these things up
um is there anything that you saw that
surprised you
no i think you know we're at a point now
where
dan you could i think you're going to be
able to turn on the top 25 rankings and
you're going to kind of put some of
these on autopilot now listen
urban meyer's situation kind of changes
things depending on what happens with
him but
the usual suspects are going to be there
i would have put i thought clemson would
have been number one
um i thought that would have been the
that's a that's a mild surprise for me
it doesn't matter in the end it's
something to talk about but
if you're looking at the top five top
six
i think for the foreseeable future top
seven you can go ahead and pencil in
alabama clemson ohio state georgia and
washington i think those are teams that
every year we're going to be talking
about three of those teams are going to
make it
uh to the college football playoff two
at the very minimum i think
three you know most seasons because of
the futures of their programs and how
they're recruiting and the success that
they've had
if i gave you the top four teams
or i gave you everybody else the field
who would you take for the national
title
oh the top four teams if i gave you the
top two
what have we seen the last couple of
years we saw versus clemson
bama versus clemson bama versus georgia
i mean i think you look at you look at
clemson's schedule this year
i find it really hard to believe that
they're not going to be there you know
jimbo fisher leaves florida state's not
going to be
maybe what florida state's been maybe
there's a learning curve with willie
taggart
who else in the league can beat them i
don't i don't see it happening
even though the last couple years
they've had a syracuse loss and a
pittsburgh lawson route to college
football playoff stuff i just
i think we're we're on course and listen
i'm okay with that in college football i
like having
i like having villains i like having
favorites because the bottom line is
there's a million there's millions and
millions of people that tuned into that
alabama georgia game going please lose
alabama
please lose next statement you know i
mean there's a
there's a there's an enemy to root
against and people don't like when
people dominate sports and we're
watching a dynasty in alabama and
dabo's obviously done great things at
clemson and i think chris peterson that
washington's got it roll i think kirby
smarts
the next nick saban in the next arrow
not not as good maybe but
he's going to have that thing rolling in
in a similar fashion i think they're
going to be in the mix
all over again so there's definitely
some there's going to be some villains
to cheer against for
everybody in college football more
pressure on notre dame or michigan this
year
michigan i think the when you look at
jim harbaugh
and his lack of success against his
rivals at some point the
hey we're happy to be michigan and being
compete competitive again and
winning nine games winning ten games
it's better than it was
you gotta beat d'antonio you gotta beat
urban meyer that's
part of your job description when you
come to michigan and he hasn't done that
in any way shape or form and
i think that's something that's gonna
have to change i think michigan people
want to see a spark on the offensive
side of the football and maybe shea
patterson provides that this year maybe
he comes in and everything changes but i
think michigan definitely
i think harbaugh is going to have some
pressure for for the first time in
michigan
when's the last time you popped somebody
uh last night youth league football
practice
well i coached i coached a 10-year team
in a 12-view team and uh
last night one of our biggest kids he's
like a buck 70 i'm like listen bro
you got to learn you got to learn how to
use your face on hands you got to fire
off the ball
and use your face i said i don't have
any pads on right now
and i'm going to fire off the ball and
i'm going to hit you i said hit me as
hard as you want to
and fired off the ball and popped him
and drove him back a little bit i was
like see it doesn't that's not about
your equipment
keep your feet moving so last night uh a
12 year old
maybe he was almost 30. he's almost 13
now feel pretty good
yeah i felt great man it just feels
great to get in a stance
and fire off and i mean it just it feels
great the football's around the corner i
know you're excited too because you're
in the show you get to talk about it man
it's just it's just it's good to smell
that smell in the air it's good to be
down here as hot as molasses in georgia
but it's good to have football back
good to visit with you david we
appreciate your time and uh have fun at
season opener in south bend should be a
lot of fun
appreciate thanks for having me dog
that's uh david pauling called me dog
big dog i went to georgia so there are
the dogs
for more dan patrick show tune to
audience channel 239 on directv
or download the dan patrick show app